in my extensive research review on
Wikipedia
it says your most played opening is the
King's Indian defense in which quote
black allows white to advance their
pawns to the center of the board in the
first two moves I is there any truth to
this
so the Kings and what is it probably is
my most played opening
um and it's one where even when my coach
who was a Grandmaster taught me he's
like so you know I've been playing the
king's Indian for 10 years and I still
don't understand it and it's one of
those openings that computers really
don't like because you do or at least
stockfish doesn't like it maybe Alpha
zero would change their mind I forgot to
look at what can you show me by the way
what it is yeah is it uh is it whites
opening or blacks opening black responds
to uh the D4 Queen's Pawn push and you
take your knight out to F6 I'll just put
in the you know stereotypical classical
Kings Indian War so to say
um so we actually have a very famous
King's Indian game and the notes that we
prepared okay
for the record I asked you guys for one
some games that you find pretty cool and
well maybe to get a chance to talk about
something yeah
um so this is the King's Indian as you
can see white has much more control over
the center white has three Pawns in the
center while black has none past the
fifth Rank and you just have this Pawn
on D6 and one of the ideas in chess is
if you're not taking the center then
your plan revolves around trying to
continually challenge it but what is
really fun about the king's Indian is
that black sometimes gets these crazy
King side attacks while white gets Queen
side attacks and even though
it's a little bit suspicious for black
and the computer could usually break it
it's hard to defend as a human when
you're being attacked but if you don't
pull off the attack as black then you're
just gonna end up being lost in the end
game so it's like a very asymmetrical
position it's very asymmetrical although
a lot of people now stop playing into
the classical King's Indian even though
computers give it a big advantage and
they play these slower lines in the
king's Indian which are less fun to play
what's slower mean it takes a longer
time to like do something interesting
with
um they basically don't let you get as
much of a king side attack because they
try opening up the center and then you
have no weaknesses but you're just
slowly improving the position of your
pieces instead of being able to go for
that King side attack so for people just
listening there is a the white pawns are
all on on the fourth row in a row
together that feels like a bad position
for black for white oh you don't like
taking the center
no I like taking the center so this is
my talking trash around oh sorry but
like
it's just like they're like feel
vulnerable they're in a row together
like it's like a like a you know because
they're like who's gonna defend them I
guess the nice Defender and the queen
defends it you're actually talking about
a theme that you do see sometimes which
is called hanging pawns and when you
have two pawns right next to each other
with no other pawns to defend them yeah
um so it it is a value valid point and
actually as black you're trying to break
apart these pawns or get them to push
and create some holes into the position
but it's a trade-off and that's a lot of
what chess openings are about you get
more space but you'll also end up having
to protect your pawns potentially or
move them forward to the point where
they're overextended